so it's Tamika yes with the tea cool
Tamika yeah Tamika what you're up where
are you from originally I am from West
Philadelphia
53rd Edison yes tell me about your
family growing up
um my mother is a lesbian so I never had
like an in-house father because I always
had like two mothers but my father was
in the picture but he's an alcoholic and
in and out of jail
so it was just my brothers and I in the
house with my mom and her wife and we
would go visit our family sometimes
and
and kind of similar to how it is today
for me like just in-house to myself how
would you describe your childhood uh
depressing but you know we had like it's
good moments
um holidays when everyone was around
um
learn how to deal with a lot of things
um
trying to impress or live up to people's
expectations type thing
no no no abuse or anything like that
well
I kind of blacked out so I don't really
remember exactly verbatim but Myron
that's my mom's first wife's little
brother
he has a little nasty ass here
it's not not a perfect childhood
no
hell no when no [ __ ]
good God no nothing perfect I'd like to
you know present it as if it was kind of
like what I just did three seconds ago
to you you know what I mean it just kind
of became a habit like drugs I guess
what made a drug start for you I'm sorry
drugs are a part of your life oh my God
yes when did that start for you that's
what it is you know like no I'm not no
drugs that would drive everything it
seems right man if I'm not doing I'm not
doing nothing without
what I want need when did I start
um and I started smoking weed when I was
13 years old and um you know drinking at
an early age and
once I got in 12th grade well my first
year was 12th grade because I did it
twice I took an ecstasy pill and I
didn't really like those too much had me
talking too much but when I got into a
bad car accident in 2009
I flew out of the car you know my head
hit the windshield I was a driver and it
hit the windshield and I flew out of the
passenger seat window
my body was real messed up they gave me
Percocets pain pills and it was on oh my
God
I was in a strip club working then and
you know I started feeling like I needed
them
needed them
went to
you know me popping all of them then I
started putting them up my nose
yeah
to your bite him off the street oh yeah
definitely I had to the first time I got
hit with a fentanyl pill was in Philly
before I even know what fentanyl was
which I can't which I found out what
that was when I came here
I've been here since 2017 since I got
out of prison yeah what kind of work
you've been doing since you've been here
manipulating
I mean lying you know uh mostly acting
yeah mainly that prostitution that you
know I do what I got to do yeah it's
just another way for it I guess do what
I got to do and what is your drug now is
fentanyl no my drug right now is crystal
meth and I'm still on opiate painkillers
you know I try to look like I'm not but
it is what it is it's my truth you know
and you work in the streets are you
working the internet or what do you do I
mean I go anywhere and everywhere that
patent Turner take me okay that's my
feet Pat the ground turn the corner got
it yeah I walk uh the street sorry
walk you know I'm not too far from a
small blade well I consider a small
blade um because I just see who I want
to see that's why I call it a small
blade you know but
I walk up there and I walk to the Dan
Casitas or to the casino rather
but
it's
it's not that's your whack you know you
meet like a lot of people want to waste
your time and I'm like I'm here to work
you know not talk and you're working
with a pimp or on your own oh on my own
I cannot follow directions too well so
I'd rather just you know stick to my own
spirit with
I can't if I [ __ ] their ass or anything
you know what I mean and where do you
stay now you're in a motel no no no I
live on 108th Street right by the police
station
in Los Angeles so
you know I take care of myself pretty
much since do you have kids no I don't I
should hold you I'm 35. 85. I don't look
35. I don't oh no I'm 87's baby
thank you
and uh
tell me about your emotional state doing
this
you get depressed you get angry you get
frustrated oh man I'm very much so
depressed a lot
um
you know it's kind of like um
like when I was younger like I just
wanted for some
I just wanted just for the people who I
cared about just accept me for how I am
and um you know because like I just
thought that love would kind of bring me
through it
and as I still live like that now I'm
still [ __ ] depressed I hate everybody
sometimes I get mad as [ __ ] that the sun
is even up like but you know like
they're like oh thank you Lord for
another day I'm just a big ass
contradiction Gemini for real I am but
um I'm very much so depressed and
that's how I was through my childhood
and I still live like that now you know
I don't want to be sad and that's why I
feel like interacting with certain
people is an acting gig not a good
paying one you know what I mean because
I don't know it's not it's not that easy
to act like you like somebody when
they're creeping you the [ __ ] out
you know talk about your tricks I'm
sorry you're talking about the tricks oh
hell yeah I'm talking about Autumn even
it wasn't I don't want to do nothing
with the ones that are undressing me
with their eyes and I'm not even you
know [ __ ] them yeah you're in a
neighborhood where everyone's a hustler
man everybody everybody anybody I'm the
only clown around that's not well you
know what I mean according to the naked
eye
good God
you know it's like I I don't wear you
know like um
what do they call them the little
slingshot outfits I don't wear like the
fishing that's outside you know I just
wear regular things and going about my
day you know and I just you're gonna get
picked up either way though oh yeah
definitely I I do get like a lot of
attention for whatever I used to I don't
know what I look like now if I look like
[ __ ] but it's really good thank you but
um you know this is I'm interviewing you
without any sleep right oh my God you
can tell yes oh you just told me that up
all night right yes I have I can't tell
but really no I know the lifestyle I
know what you guys are doing it's it's
what time is it now it's 11 in the
morning yeah you've been up all night
man yeah and it was raining last night
yeah tonight
do you recall your first time doing this
yes I do how was we I was 4 15. a guy
went down on me when my first girlfriend
broke my little heart and Smithereens
you know it was sad
he paid me in all [ __ ] quarters
in quarters a big bag of change right
and it's crazy because I should have
known then these [ __ ] gonna try to
play you straight up but I did not like
grasp that concept until
just a few minutes ago honestly
when I thought about it like [ __ ] I
should have known then you know
he was a [ __ ]
I'm man and that's like why I do not
like am I allowed to like say this I
don't like guys going down on me don't
no don't do that because that [ __ ] did
that [ __ ] you know and it just takes me
way back somewhere else and I wish that
was one thing that I couldn't remember
but you know
um just don't touch my [ __ ] whatever on
my [ __ ]
that's what they want to do right I'm
sorry that's what they all want to do
man you know that's what yeah that's
what they say but I
[ __ ] that I don't even think they know
what the [ __ ] they want to do most of
the time they just want to do every damn
thing under the sun it ain't enough time
in the world for that
I'm just grateful that I still have time
to be here on this Earth in an OD
like [ __ ] three times like you know
If Looks can kind of Carry Me Through
man I wouldn't even be here talking to
you you know
this kind of work has changed the way
you see men
um
the way I see women really yeah they're
evil is mean as [ __ ]
you know
um
like I hear you know a lot of stories
about you know men treating women wrong
because of what they do
honestly I mean like you know what I
mean the guys that I do interact with
and kind of you know discuss what I do
with
um they don't really treat me any
differently I guess to me now the women
once they it's like rare oh no you know
what I mean I walk into a damn into a
store for example when someone's
grabbing on their husband giving me
their [ __ ] oh their cold shoulder
like dang lady I'm just trying to buy
some damn squash and some peanuts I'm
not in here trying to you know me work
you or your ugly ass man but call me
he's like you know what I'm saying
but yeah it's just kind of like made
women treat you like [ __ ]
or maybe that's just where I perceive it
honestly I feel like everyone looks at
me like
ooh that's the girl who's on drugs and
you know so I kind of personalized a lot
of things
yeah I heard lifestyle to be I'm sorry
it's a hard lifestyle to be existing and
everyone's out to out to to get you yeah
for real the people in the lifestyle
that work they want to take you out
whether it's men or women and then it's
like you know the men want you to
themselves they so they can [ __ ] for
free that's not what I signed up here
for sir you know no that's not going to
happen and then whenever they catch
feelings
you're supposed to like now those are
your feelings man you know you're like
my life it's two different dashes you
know what I mean
and what I mean by Dash is between your
birthday the day you're born and the day
you die it's like a little Dash you know
we all have one that's mine like yours
is yours it's your [ __ ] your feelings
mine is mine I mean
you get feelings that don't mean you get
free ass not for me
did you have dreams of doing something
else with your life when you were
younger
what do you want to do I just knew I was
going to be a teacher you know
but this is a different way I guess do
you regret giving up on that
honestly I don't regret giving up on
that simply because I still do right
like that kind of did change over time
because I still write poems
um I do actually
I actually do want to start a non-profit
you know what I mean for people who are
still suffering from childhood trauma
um
till this day into adulthood and also
children mainly like juvenile
delinquents just to like kind of get
them to alter and twist their ways up
which can turn them towards the street
and being exposed to [ __ ] they'll lead
them to stuff like this or just in the
streets in general you know because
when like growing up in broken homes
we're not
like we don't learn everything we don't
understand that you know we can change
our mind well I know I didn't I learned
at 29 when I was in prison you know I
didn't know that I was able to not be
like this girl or you know what I mean
not do those one thing so anyway back to
my non-profit I just want to teach those
little things so hopefully you know
someone who wants to be a teacher won't
end up being a dumb hoe like me
but do you feel like the things you went
through as a child or what or why you're
in this situation today I'm sorry do you
feel like the things you went through as
a child are why you're in this situation
today
um yeah some sometimes most of the time
I do because I just wanting somebody
just not getting over the fact that I
need to love myself versus looking you
know to for everyone else to do it for
me it seems like the child's abuse
derails the ability to love yourself yes
oh hell yeah hell yeah hell yeah
isn't it but I still just want I don't
know it's you know it's kind of like
it's easier to do something for someone
else than it is to do for yourself
that's how I feel
you know like
like I don't know I'm more motivated to
do it for others like oh but my
boyfriend to the T
you know what I mean I'll show him this
and that but what do I got to show me I
am me that's like backwards you think
I hope I'm like making sense so I'm
feeling sounds stupid
do you think you get desensitized to the
dangers that are out there
after you've been doing this for a while
um you can't normalize at all
sadly but yeah like I I haven't you know
gotten like um you know hit or like
raped or when I buy a trick you know
what I'm saying I only told them that
but by a customer client
um but I actually got raped by a pimp
a year and a half ago
like just he was just trying to talk to
me didn't want to tell me he was a
parent you know so it's just a booby
trap I guess
you know
whatever's dangerous and I still do walk
as if you know ain't [ __ ] going to
happen to me because I do like to put my
mind to what it is that I want versus
what it is that versus not you know
folks that know what I don't want you
know because you do get whatever the
[ __ ] you put your energy into
your friends
no
no
I don't none of the girls that do this
kind of work tell me they have friends
very few my friend she she they're dead
my friends aren't here they're gone
I have one friend she's Tasha Marie she
passed away uh with the needle in her
arm
about a couple years ago
she that was that was my [ __ ] that was
like Mommy
friend who
you know thugged it out understood each
other accept each other encouraged each
other it was still there through the
fighting and all that that's love that's
a friend
I hear the people around you're not your
friend they're only around for what they
want
and that's it but I'm not supposed to be
around for what I want [ __ ] out of here
you know and I'm not their friend either
like [ __ ] it what's your biggest fear at
this point in your life
damn
I don't know I don't really
I don't really want to say that but
physically getting my nose broke other
than that
sometimes I like I said I don't be let's
be ready to go
why the [ __ ] is the Sun up like you know
why can't I be sleep in a cave like what
do you what do you think most people
don't understand about girls that do
this kind of work
um
the the strength that it takes to do
what it is that you got to do
and you're going to do it regardless
they don't understand that
so you know don't
pick at us like for bullies don't
disrespect us as if you know we're not
grandmothers or mothers or sisters or
whatever the case is you know because we
are still you know people
how do you think doing this kind of work
has changed you
it has made me
more honestly I just started dealing
with more [ __ ] from using it from from
in straight up
might be real [ __ ] because you know
because I know what I do I sell my ass
for a living okay I'm gonna deal with
you [ __ ] my sister I'm gonna deal
with you you know what I mean slapping
the [ __ ] out of me just because I know
that you deal with me you know what I'm
saying selling my ass
just because this nigga's a boyfriend
does not mean that
he has to [ __ ] me too you know what I
mean straight up
and that made me deal with a lot of
extra [ __ ] just to have them around
that's that's how it changed me
so I just feel so dumb like what the
[ __ ] is that about
it's the hardest part of this lifestyle
for you
um
not wanting to do it well no I'm sorry
my period straight up because it ain't
[ __ ] gonna happen
that's honestly that's just like the
hardest part about it I really don't
I'm a pretty optimistic person when it
comes to me you know but I do accept my
reality and
it's not you know it's all the same if
you're addicted to this lifestyle
oh my God I don't want to do anything
else that's money and all that I don't
even think I think about sometimes
getting a job but come on for what if I
can do this here I pay my own bills I
you know what I mean I do here for me
only thing is I guess so like a paycheck
job it'll save me money kind of because
it'll be all you know held until
whenever they want to pay me you know
been in love so far I'm sorry you've
been involved before have I been in love
oh my God yeah
yes
I have
I still am
does this lifestyle kind of get in the
way of
your relationships your personal
relationship
um right now currently I feel like it
does because like I'm doing more lying
I'm lying and I'm more Moody like I want
to talk to you but I can't say why so
I'm screaming out [ __ ] that I don't
wanna you know what I mean that I don't
even mean because
you know I'm pretty straightforward
person and I'm not a good liar so when I
lie it's
you know he calls and says what are you
doing you know what's up with you why
are you acting like that acting like
what you know of course I try to beat
him mad like [ __ ] that I'm gonna get mad
now like
just because I can't tell you the truth
and this is what it is you know
like sometimes I think about
just going back home
but I ain't no Runner
you know
I just you know hope and pray to God
that I
somehow someway do that I do discover
when it is just to
surrender all the way and and when is
that going to come for me this is
something just like [ __ ] this [ __ ] man
you don't mean go back home because it's
something that I'm holding on to you
know just either the control of things
or control of my finances the control of
just not you know
I don't know not making it out here but
I'm gonna make it out this [ __ ]
just like I have been you know
but I just don't want to go back home
because of that my family's gonna look
at me like oh she didn't make it
I gotta let that go I just want to gain
that out of this
you think there's a better chance of you
getting aged out or quitting on your own
and doing something else
the route I'm going laying up dead who
knows
or dead yeah
the route I'm going because like how can
I not like live fearlessly in this and
it's it's not this is not the [ __ ]
Sesame Street or Barney's playground you
know what I'm saying
is this is the streets are rough man as
hell you know maybe in Philly is just
like a little different though you know
because I was always just the only one
walking by myself I'm doing my own thing
walking you know but out here I don't
know these streets I don't know these
people I don't even understand what the
[ __ ] is going on those second time so
uh yeah the route I'm going I'm end up
but yeah
do you think any woman can do this kind
of work
I think anyone can do anything that they
put their mind to but
no
any woman
like what age is considered a woman
you feel me when I was four no not four
but like 14 I wasn't considered a
[ __ ] woman because you were doing it
you feel me
but now
you know it's just all about perception
like I said you put do anything that you
put your mind to
what advice would you give to a
a woman or a girl who's thinking of
doing this
well do I gotta say it or can I like
slap it to him like nah this ain't it
you know
um Express Yourself
talk about how you feel and don't hold
it in so it doesn't turn you to things
that will expose you to [ __ ] that your
gullible little mind and brain isn't
going to want to attack adapt to out of
curiosity
that makes sense
you believe in karma yes
how does karma play out in your life
well karma is in the you know
karma really doesn't come around in good
forms I guess karma is like negative and
I don't do [ __ ] [ __ ] to people so
I don't worry about that either
I believe you know honestly I want to go
back to one question that you did ask me
I um I do feel that I'm protected you
know because I don't do [ __ ] you know
what I mean that's probably why I do
you know feel Fearless towards the
dangers of being you know what I mean
because I'm very in tune with my star
player with me you know and and with God
I have my own personal relationship and
you know
Fearless fearful for what tourism
streets now I'm more fearful for me of
me you know what I mean I don't want to
putting pills up my nose and you know
smoking [ __ ] like
what's your biggest regret
um
my biggest regret uh
[ __ ]
working in a strip club I think
no that's not it
let me useful
I was just kind of leaning towards
something
exposure me to drugs but I don't even
regret that I don't know getting smart
to my parents I mean straight up lying
to my parents how about that
that's my biggest [ __ ] regret because
if I didn't feel like I had to hold up a
certain facade
I probably would have been God
your parents know you're doing this
no
um
no
I probably do now they might after this
here yeah I'm certain they will
are you saving money
I don't know how to do that what is that
oh man tell me about the guys who pick
you up
talk about them what about them
are they married
I don't I don't know
they don't you know that should go in my
ear and out the other some of them lie
you know what sometimes they are married
and they say that they're not so I don't
know how to answer that question being
truthful but I'll tell you this true ass
story my first date
I swear to God this man's wife popped up
to my [ __ ] door
what the [ __ ] was that you said you're
not married so I'll say maybe 50 of them
are married you know what I mean and
other 50 aren't because just with that
one [ __ ] he told me that you're
not [ __ ] married and your wife comes
to my door after you leave so I don't
know they're all married if you ask me
you know they're married to something
somebody
the reason why they want to take your
number and you don't they don't give you
theirs
Tamika what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
um
don't just
um
ask questions and only a phrase ask
questions otherwise you'll end up doing
some [ __ ] you know what I mean
if you don't even know what the [ __ ]
you're doing
mm-hmm
you know I hope that the questions that
you are asking me I'm like making myself
kind of clear because a lot of people
they're not able to follow me
but I know it makes sense to me what I'm
saying
you know
all right Tamika thank you so much for
sharing your story you're welcome I wish
you lots of luck thank you thank you
thank you